so you you were telling me earlier this
was your first American film which seems
incredible because you had such a
storied career before this yes I worked
in Germany with basically with
Fassbender which I knew when he was 14
and a half and I was 15
we met in a working class bass with for
that time very advanced of transvestite
truck drivers and if somebody made a
strange remarked I gotta just be a
bottle in their face that's how we met
and then later on we started working
together and we worked together till
basically till he died and then there
was of course in Germany that time we
had only a few directors I was better
you always have to be reckoned on okay
they have hat sock with vendors and fast
Binda yes and I'm sorry you didn't tell
me to have a mustache in my own private
I know I would have loved to have a
mustache saying do you want to be my
friend no it was I was in Germany and
then first been unfortunately died very
young much too young and I met gas in
Berlin Milan OCHA and he came to me and
we were talking about and I sorry I
Fassbender and gas once and and they
were i lonely at festivals they talk a
lot but he did not only talk he got me
the work permit I came to America I made
my first film and now 25 years later I'm
still here I cannot see you because I
just see so strong light and I'm very
happy that was my first film with great
actors River Phoenix was unbelievable it
cost me a lot of money because he was
such a kind of method act
that he called me hands and I had to pay
so when we went out and evening he said
Hunt's pay and I had a I had a sack
union contract was different so I I am
also a big fuss bender fan but I have to
imagine that Gus is temperamentally the
polar opposite of Faust bender to work
with is that true or is that first of
all I'll be here to talk about gas yeah
exactly
Fassbender is okay
alright I've often wondered and like and
I will do this actually now that I live
out with you I can record and all your
stories about as well the difference is
that Fassbender i remember we made a
film called the circulation with Hannah
she gula playing my wife and we walked
in her in a room and somebody said why
are you fighting and it was not in the
script
and I said we're not fighting Fassbender
left the camera went to his room I had
to be all there knocking on the door
saying sorry sorry because I ever had
the brief moment of inventing one
sentence gas was totally different I'd
said to a gas in the film you will see
it was a very interesting scene I told
him I told him I went to Moscow and I
was singing in Moscow and they forgot to
give me the microphone so I had a lamp
and put it right away into my microphone
singing into a lamp which was actually
good because I realized I could work
with it I could do my own lighting and
the people in the Russian stadium they
were from Pink Floyd I said who's this
[ __ ] person we give him all the light
and he comes off in a flash lamp and
anyway that's a story and then there's
um you know the first day you arrived
well maybe on the first day but you had
a cassette you had a lot of ideas and
you one of them was the cassette
from videos that you would made and the
and also abused performance performances
that he had had and we shot it we that
was what was know you say actually do
you cannot hear the tape yeah oh and
then we realized that we have to have
this I remember it very well and you say
can I have the tape I gave you the tape
you took it home it came back the next
morning when we had two sex scenes with
the boys and you said to me why don't
you sing to the boys I said what I sing
before I have sex okay and he said why
don't you take that big lamp
I said no when I told you it was a small
lamp and he gave me the big lamp which
was like that and the technician had to
me that long cable and that's what you
see later when I have this big lamp and
thinking is sitting on a bullet thinking
of power every hour so I had to do this
and I think let's not talk so much about
me let's talk about cars